now anime any mere human area first I
was the person being El Arish hospital
for a minute or is it
I started to cough blood I was my lungs
got really I don't know I'm really
damaged and piss
Oh Veronica now you can ma I'm a caramel
Fe padam oh sorry we dropped on a meter
body
Sharon glad they are about some sensor
and the matter pal but no they still
hadn't moved wha and you sure don't do
any adobe.com cinema Sarah must be
German - terrible no shoe had the
initial dodgy if you wanna torture
I don't want with my surrender damage
I think that the the photograph speak
for themselves the partners of injuries
are so clear and they they clearly show
that these people has been starved to
death and many of them they clearly show
injury patterns that are not consistent
with Falls they are consistent with
torture
you